we'll talk to Fran Fraschilla the SPN
college basketball analyst he was on the
call last night Kansas Kansas State and
this is how it sounded courtesy of
Learfield IMG he poster rises the cats
and now there's a scrub players from
both sides into the handicapped section
behind the basket there are fans and
ball trying to separate the Wildcats and
this just is ugly as the kayuu student
section during the Wildcats who were
trying to get one more play vadik
blocked that time by silvio de sousa
ended the game and then silvio kinda
stared down at the Wildcat he just
rejected which I believe was poured
let's bring in friend for shilla he was
on the call last night Fran thanks for
joining us was there anything leading up
to this was it chippy I know it's a
rivalry game did you see anything that
preceded this no Dan the only thing is
there's a common etiquette as you know
in basketball when a team is up and
dribbling out the clock and the young
man Gordon from Kansas State freshman
really competitive Chicago player day
year last year he steals the ball from
de sousa the Soza runs them down makes a
great block and then the de sousa stands
over Gordon and that's when the melee
ensued a little back story here the
soules is the young man who has gotten
involved in Kansas involved with all
this n-c-double-a stuff as you may know
he's not playing much he's out of the
rotation it was in the game way you know
amateur psychiatrist I think he just
brushed was frustrated with the whole
situation and and it escalated when he
stood over the k-state guy it was
pushing and shoving and then he went
Mike Tyson on everybody so it was a wild
scene for sure now I can look at this
from a variety of angles literally and
figuratively but when I start to think
of the assistant coaches keeping their
players
on the bench you know did was there a
situation where the players were told to
back off I believe Bruce Weber Kansas
State's head coach said you know hey
let's ease off here we're getting blown
out here yeah
is that a bush-league steal given the
score of the game let me start there
yeah yeah no it's it's funny I talked to
a couple coaching buddies of mine this
morning and it's it's it's not good
etiquette let's put it that way I get
the competition built Bill Self was fine
with the play said look my guys got to
protect the ball if you're still being
guarded and you're playing a team where
two coaches you know hey we're going to
play a whole 40 minutes and you know
we're never going to give up until the
horn goes off you kind of got to be
prepared for that but a basketball
etiquette you let the game dribble out I
would have put that that way and the
Illinois play where the kid steps on the
guy's chest yeah kind of christian
Laettner like if you remember back
Duke Kentucky and I would I would show
my team that and say look you know we
haven't gone over this play particularly
but this is how we're going to handle
this you never try to steal it when
you're up and it's it's something that
both coaches I was at the press
conferences Dan they were very contrite
schools it's an embarrassment the best
analogy I can give you is that I've
called 75 games in Allen Fieldhouse and
I call it the st. Patrick's Cathedral of
collar of college basketball it's
hallowed ground imagine going into st.
Patrick's on Fifth Avenue and you're
going in there to light a candle and you
know sit down say a prayer say a rosary
and a brawl breaks out in Saint
Patrick's Cathedral that's how jarring
it was last night it's it's a least
likely place you would expect something
like this even given the rivalry because
of the you know the class of the Kansas
program what kind of punishment do you
dole out here well I was harsh last
night and I said I think the souls is
going to get I wouldn't be surprised if
you suspend it for the season in part
because and by the way the hero here is
assistant coach Kansas jaren's Howard
who took the took the stool
away from de sousa because you could
only imagine what where we'd be today if
he hit somebody over the head and
someone's in critical condition so thank
God it seems like nobody was hurt but a
major suspension will come down from the
league office I'm sure by later today
and if it's if it's ten games if it's a
season they'll adjudicate it properly I
think a couple other guys on both teams
will be suspended for the next game and
the sad part about this is College
GameDay comes in two Allen Fieldhouse on
Saturday for the end yeah so you know
how we are DSP and this is a so this
will be top of mind we'll be running the
replays back more than the Zapruder film
and in unfortunately and really I'm
telling you man
and I know how much you love basketball
there's no place like Allen Fieldhouse
yeah the fans are great their class even
in the rivalry they treat the k-state
with relative respect given the rivalry
just an unfortunate situation that just
smiled out of control I think in part
because the young man's frustration with
not playing much you speak of Allen
Fieldhouse I thought so much of the
building I paid for my own way out there
to watch a game when Kansas hosted Jason
Kidd and Cal I just wanted to see a
great game there and I went out just to
watch the game and of course to see you
know Jason Kidd against Kansas we're
talking to Fran Fraschilla of the
mothership this weekend ESPN will be
broadcasting big 12 SEC challenge
tipping off at noon Eastern West
Virginia Missouri and then Iowa State at
number nine Auburn on ESPNU I the thing
I thought about today after listening to
everything that happened last night
seeing the highlights last night is is
this enough for Bill Self to just go I
think I'm gonna leave college basketball
you're under investigation you have this
you're gonna go into the college
basketball hall you're gonna go into the
Basketball Hall of Fame yeah do you see
him going and taking over let's say the
San Antonio Spurs well I don't see the
Spurs that's too logical you know I know
the relationship with RC Buford but you
know I've told people you know great Bob
it just got acolytes all over NBA you
know guys that have worked for him well
why would why would he not take a guy
and bill as close to their team and
their program and his son Tyler is a
scout for the Spurs I don't see that
this disc NC double-a will be
adjudicated at the end of the summer so
we don't really know how harsh a penalty
it'll be I mean that the consensus is
it's going to be a very harsh penalty
for you know for Bill and the program
and but I don't see the Spurs but I do
think this is a you know it's funny Dan
everybody sees Bill selfie and by the
way he's already in the Hall of Fame oh
yes yeah he's a Naismith Hall of Famer
ready and you know he's always
twenty-nine and four and they and
they've got great fans and I'm just
telling you someone who's around him a
lot you know everybody's got their own
issues this is a major cloud the NC
double-a thing and and now this my gut
feeling is he will be in the NBA soon
but I won't be with the Spurs I could
see somebody like Chicago Bulls or you
know somebody that's on the way up and
maybe not as bad a team as the Cavaliers
that'd be line took over I will say this
the difference between the NBA and
college in terms of coaching is like
Spanish and Portuguese they sound alike
they're two completely different
languages but but having said that there
are only a handful of guys in my mind
maybe three or four at the most that
could make the adjustment that Brad
Stevens has Bill Self as one is one of
them he is a excellent excellent
basketball coach who makes adjustments
what you have to do in the NBA he's one
of the few guys I think could handle
that my guy Calipari now you're not
screaming at guys in the NBA okay no I
love I love John you're not going to do
that Bill Self has a touch with players
and I think would wear well in the NBA
and I wouldn't be surprised if in the
next 12-24 months he says you know I
like a new challenge I'll leave you with
this and one of the reasons why I love
having you on when we get closer to the
draft is you're as knowledgeable about
the foreign players the European players
is anybody I've ever been around and
always appreciated your insight I go
back to Luca dhansak and and I when I
saw his highlights and granted everybody
looks good in their highlights he always
looked like he was just a little bit
ahead of everybody on everything he did
he didn't look like he was dramatically
ahead of them just got his shot off just
beat you to the layup just just a little
but he's he's doing that in the NBA here
how surprised are you with what Don
cheek has done so far well I'm surprised
I'm shocked I mean I thought he would be
good i-i-i had eight and one dodge too
and most people did I thought he'd be
very good then I really did but this is
generational what he's doing I mean
we're talking bird magic
LeBron you don't average 29 9 and 10 as
a 20 year old I think he turns 21 in
February and he's the guy he's the he's
the fat guy at the Y who you know when
you go who's that guy I used to be a
really good college player and you guys
can't be that good I mean look at him he
still got baby fat on
I am shocked because he's toying with
the NBA at 20 years old it's not like
he's going to be the next turd for his
guy he'll he's you know porzingis has
got some potential when we when he came
out this guy is toying with the NBA
think about it I'm gonna say it again
twenty nine nine and ten every single
night against the greatest players in
the world at 20 years old and that bet
that's the first line in a resume who if
he stays healthy we're talking bird
Jordan magic you name him
LeBron that's how good he's already
started his career and Zion makes his
debut tonight you got to see a lot of
him last year in college what do you eat
healthy if he's healthy Dan he's a
monster
I think if and he's holed up he's also
generational I would be surprised I
wouldn't be surprised if he gets 25
tonight you know I don't know how the
rehab is gone but if and when he's at a
hundred percent I do think he's going to
be a dominant NBA
Claire he's a he's a cartoon character
if somebody hasn't seen his game and you
were going to describe his game how
would you describe Sion well I would say
like well we put this way when they do
Space Jam 3 in 8 or 9 years
he's the he's that's the protagonist you
know I mean like he's a cartoon
character he's a freak athlete grew a
good skill level great IQ for the game
and then you know I said this last
December a billy we should say a
million-dollar smile right he's got a
billion dollar smile okay I asked this
to Reggie Miller yesterday I'm going to
ask you if you're Memphis would you take
JA Morant or Zion Williamson well I take
John Moran because I know what I'm
getting with Zion that the concern is
we've never seen a kid this young this
in quickly insanely athletic at 280
pounds and the concern has always been
Kenny holds up over 10 or 12 or 15 years
I thought John Moran would be an
all-star last year said so not this not
you know not back back dating my opinion
here and I know what I'm already getting
with John you know in a week that values
open-floor artistry like the westbrook's
the hardens the curries this is this is
the next guy and so I would take the
given versus what I think is going to be
special and diet great to talk to you
Fran is always safe travels thanks for
joining us
always a pleasure Dan Thank You Fran
Fraschilla ESPN college basketball games
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]